come on
look at this
that was a weird cut
i don't understand this
hey what's up guys we are back with
stuntman react we have a very special
guest today amy johnson thanks for
having me this is the second time that
she's come out guys the kicks are high
the impacts they're solid they land
right
hopefully every single time i am very
excited to hear your insight on all this
stuff and i know you guys are excited
too so let's jump right in
dude liam liam neeson's
and i'm excited to be taken away
by this scene all right let's just see
if it's close-up grunts and moves on
liam neeson's part and then just cuts to
a wide angle of stunt man taking a hard
hit
whoa whoa whoa
christian were you fast forwarding that
let's try that one more time let's try
that one more time
there's like a flash of his face poorly
framed just the darkly nissan's faces
let's count the frames
okay so far so good like you know okay
i don't know what's going on there it's
time framed up that was a cut right
there
what what
what is happening
totally
dude there's never a rhythm change it's
just cut cut cut cut cut cut i think
it's more
[Applause]
yeah
it's gonna be a really cool shot guys
i'm gonna get this arm and then i'm get
the other side of his arm it's so bad
this movie's a parody of itself filming
the comedy version of this would be so
funny we did kind of we did a parody of
this it's like can you take anything and
make it cool with hyper cuts crazy
camera work and like just
nonsensical editing
action
on the next episode of stuntman react we
react to the fight scene we just filmed
it killed bill yes
that's zoe bell for sure
that was a weird cut
oh she just jumped by herself yeah
that's really weird i can't believe
that's in the actual movie how would you
have fixed that i'd throw in an insert
of just like the person going find
something that could sell that she's
doing a kick and then you can just put
the sound effect in
that's so good the school bus like you
know it's like oh crap oh that face
so much emotion it makes like a typical
fight more interesting because now
there's going to be a kid involved
there's a school bus like they're in her
home she's looking at her plates when
she hits them she's like oh i paid
however much money for that like there's
little elements that make this fight
something more than just kicks and
punches
oh that's so cool i love that dude that
shot shooting into the camera like that
i love that she didn't just throw her
cup of coffee she dropped it then kicked
it man that cereal box is a really
dangerous prize inside for kids
now inside specially marked boxes of
circus
are you subscribed let me try that again
are you subscribed
please press the subscribe button please
chris why do i i can't
i got one hey
i got this niko i got this hey hey clint
just subscribe already please all right
you watch all these videos you're not
subscribed i don't get it it helps us
out it's very easy for you to do and i'm
not mad anymore because i saw you just
subscribe so thank you
[Music]
so guys we're talking about stunts here
we have to talk about jackie chan are we
ever gonna run out of jackie chan clips
nope
come on
oh my god come on you have one shot at
that look at this it's amazing and
there's people there too look at this
look at this okay i can see just sending
two stunt guys down through this like
favela looking thing but when you
involve people it's immediately like the
the safety and risk factor just right
because you might not be able to see a
car when there's a bunch of buildings
coming through
the explosions just the explosion it's
coming a little closer yeah it's right
there oh i felt the heat all right jump
[Music]
did they build these buildings for their
shot i feel like you had to have built
all this stuff you can kind of see
there's like built ramps or streets that
they're driving through there's so many
explosions each time they come down like
i figured they have to do this multiple
times to get different angles but
they're breaking through so many
different things so it'd be a huge reset
i don't understand this like initially
i'm thinking there's just a bunch of
cameras and they're getting as much as
they can with one time going down
probably they had one wide shot they had
one chance at a true wide and then they
maybe had a couple that are like still
kind of wide feeling and then all the
inserts probably all the cameras were
set up ready to go how do you think this
scene would be shot in america today my
guess is if we shot this in america it'd
be a lot quicker like smaller setups
they wouldn't do a full take the cars
will be way more in control
there's also a very similar scene in bad
boys too so let's take a look at that
oh nico you're right already like single
scenes individuals lots of inside the
car actors actors actors
oh that's a nice moment yeah that's
crazy how similar these scenes are i
mean it's clearly inspired i'm not gonna
lie i kind of think this one's shot a
little bit better than jackie's like
jackie's had that has a raw chaos that
chaotic energy this one feels like like
these are gonna be some cool moments
here let's set up for them
how sketchy is this
dude what okay oh my god
things definitely hit it oh look at that
rope in the foreground and then you see
the second car coming that's great it's
pretty good
yeah but there's something about seeing
people like jump off of buildings at the
last second because they don't know
which way the car is coming and like all
of that chaos from police store is
amazing that's true that's completely
missing from this i don't get the the
what you know reaction i it's like oh
crazy they're doing this but it's not
like a what you know this does have that
edge of reality about it though that
like the bad boys two one kind of lacks
i mean the bad boys two one has punch
don't get me wrong like this definitely
feels like a wow this is insane i've
never seen anything like this before
kind of shot i like this better i'm
gonna say it
you can't really top that there's
explosions there's cars there's people
there's everything
i like how he's buckled up by the way
he takes the time to unbuckle that's how
amazing jackie is hasn't he broken like
most of his bones he's broken his hip
he's broken his spine he's broken his
neck back in his skull it went chipped
into his brain that's when he got good
at singing that's when he was like i'm
going to take up my singing career is
that really the moment well when he was
in the hospital he was like i need to
reinvent myself so he he put out albums
album after album
[Music]
next time if i come back here i want to
make sure that there are lots of
comments from you all on fight scenes
that you want to see maybe some more
awesome like fight scenes like that and
anything that we're missing like there's
so many cool things out there so please
next time i'm here
make sure there's lots of goodies in the
comment section
[Music]
dude you fall into those treads you get
sucked right under and you die yeah
i wonder if it's not a real tank i don't
know if it's like a shell put on top of
like a car platform so there's like
aren't real treads they don't actually
touch the ground i almost guarantee you
that's not a real tank there because
they got cameras on it and stuff like
that all these guys walking on it i bet
you it's a specialty that's a good point
what's this
we had another tank which was built from
aluminium and this tank was pulled along
by an open back truck so we could put
the cameras on it and things like that
the treads aren't on the ground hey look
at that it's raised up so this stunt it
was such a bigger deal
but it was a real tank but now i know
it's on a trailer it's not so bad
[Laughter]
yeah i built an old uh what is it m1a1
abrams tank took us a year really yeah
we mounted it on top of a car we built
it out of cardboard drove it around
that's awesome ruined my friend's mom's
car
radiator blue
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh yeah definitely it's interesting
because he has like a blind shot he's
looking at the other side like a red
square it looks like as soon as he sees
that he's blindly rolling and hoping
that he hit the right spot at the right
right it's perfect it's so good oh my
gosh he could have really hurt himself
how are they how are they doing this
with harrison ford it's still styrofoam
it's gotta be once again it's gotta be a
fake tank there it looks amazing though
fake tank fake wall yeah but it looks so
good
[Music]
fun fact that's gimli really yep and
let's just have his head and be done
with it this stuff is like timeless this
yeah they don't do this anymore in
movies the thing i love about those real
stunts like when they don't use cg when
they don't have like a you know computer
generated character filling in the
middle and stuff there's an element of
like this is possible in real life you
know so this heroic guy indiana jones
he's in this hairy situation how can he
get out of it it's possible it's humanly
possible to fall into the tank tread
roll off the side and grab the gun
because the guy just did it there's
something about that promise like i find
that thrilling yes it keeps you in the
movie it sucks you in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
amy thank you so much for joining us
today so amy actually put out a book
called how to stunt in hollywood it's
all about how to get into the industry
the do's and don'ts i have a new um
audiobook version out now so
so go check it out and we'll see you
guys next time on the next episode maybe
maybe middle of the week
maybe end of the week probably both
honestly